JULIUS KAMMERL:
Hello, everybody.
My name is Julius Kammerl.
I'm a software engineer
and the tech lead
for our spatial audio
efforts for virtual reality,
here at Google.
First of all, thank
you so much for coming.
It's really great to see so
much interest for spatial audio
here at Google I/O this year.
And we're extremely
excited to share with you
our spatial audio
rendering engine, which
is included in the Google
VR SDK, Google's platform
for high-quality mobile VR.
Very early on in the project,
we made an experiment
where we tried to simulate
all aspects of how
humans perceive sound.
And these results have
been so incredible
that this immediately
became a serious project.
And today we have made available
our best-in-class spatial audio
rendering solution
for mobile devices,
with zero compromise in quality.
This means now you can get a
truly realistic spatial audio
experience on a mobile
device for free.
And we know you're
going to love this.
So today-- together
with my colleagues
Ian, Alper, and
Adam-- will share
a lot of background information
about the technology
that we created for you.
Specifically, you will
learn about the importance
of high-quality spatial
audio for virtual reality.
We will explain how spatial
audio works in our real world,
and how we can simulate
that in our SDK.
And parts may sound
complex, but we
will show you how easy it is
to add spatial audio to your VR
experiences.
We will show you
the very few steps
needed to create
really compelling
spatial audio experiences.
And we will share user
design recommendations,
which will help you to
optimize your audio assets
and create amazing experiences.
So you see, you hear a
lot of cool stuff today.
Spatial audio has
a long history.
Already, stereo recordings
provided a first sense
of spaciousness since we are
able to pan a phantom source
between two speakers.
And over the years, more and
more speakers were added.
Here we see a 5.1
setup, which allows you
to horizontally panel source.
7.1 provides more elevation.
And now we are in
the VR era, where
technologies like ambisonics
provide true audio immersion.
We are able to play back sound
sources from all directions,
and we are able to simulate
real-world acoustics in VR.
And in VR, spatial
audio is vital.
If someone calls your name, you
know immediately where to look.
If you drop a coin,
you know immediately
the direction it rolled.
Why?
Because we hear directionally.
We perceive the location
of sound sources
in our environment.
So how does that apply to VR?
In VR, we put the user into
the middle of the action,
and he might not even
know where to look.
Spatial audio provides
a powerful tool
to control user attention.
By providing spatial audio cues
from the direction of interest,
we can guide a user
through a VR experience.
But it's not only a powerful
content-creation tool.
The illusion of being
in a different world
immediately breaks
as soon as there's
a mismatch between our senses.
And particularly, the
lack of spatial audio
immediately breaks
in VR immersion.
So in this context,
it's really important
that spatial audio
deserves a lot of attention
from content creators like you.
So in order to
bring spatial audio
to VR, the first question
we should ask ourselves is,
how does spatial audio
work in our real world?
Let's take a look
at what happens
when a sound wave
propagates through a room
and hits a human head.
The first thing
we notice here is
that there's a time difference
between the sound wave hitting
the left and the right ear, and
that time difference depends
on the location of
your sound source.
The more the sound source is
to the left or to the right,
the larger the
time difference is.
So just using the time
difference doesn't work.
At the moment where we
consider high frequencies ,
the size of the sound waves
traveling through the air
becomes smaller
than the human head.
So at approximately
1.5 kilohertz,
this is exactly
what is happening.
At this moment, the
human brain isn't
able to differentiate
anymore if it's
the same sound wave
hitting both ears,
or if we have two
separate sound waves.
So just using the time
difference alone doesn't help.
We need more.
And in fact, the
human brain also
uses the level differences.
The human head creates
an acoustic shadow,
which damps high frequencies.
And at approximately
1.5 kilohertz and above,
we use these level differences
to localize sound objects,
as well.
So we've heard of time
differences and level
differences.
But unfortunately,
that's not enough.
Consider a sound source in
your front or in your back.
It would have the same
time and level differences.
What about a sound source at
two o'clock and four o'clock?
Again, that would have the same
time and level differences.
In fact, you can draw a set of
cones on the sides of each ear,
and every sound source on
the surface of each cone
would have the same time
and level differences.
So how do we humans
deal with that?
We do two things.
First, we move our head.
We move our head all
the time, and I'm
sure you have seen dogs
doing the same thing.
They have a very precise
spatial audio perception system.
So what happens when
we move our head?
This is illustrated here.
On the left side, we see a
sound source in our front
and in our back, and it results
in the same time and level
differences.
At the moment where
we move our head,
these level and time
differences change
in exact opposite
direction, which
helps us to resolve
these ambiguities
in the horizontal domain.
But what about the
vertical domain?
Here we use those
guys-- our outer ears.
They act as a special
pair of filters
that are highly-unique to us.
They create something like
an acoustic fingerprint
to everything we hear.
And when sound waves
arrive at our ears,
they bounce off inside
the so-called pinna
in different ways,
depending on the direction
of the sound wave.
In this way, our outer
ears act as a filter,
which depends on the direction
of the sound waves arriving.
And again, by moving
our head and listening
for the changes in
spectral frequencies,
we can localize objects in 3D.
But let's not be selfish.
Spatial audio is
not only about us.
It's also about the environment.
Sound waves do not only
bounce off our ears.
They bounce off everything
that surrounds us.
First comes the
direct sound, then we
hear so-called
early reflections,
which are the first
strong reflections--
reflections from
objects, probably, nearby
and that are still strong enough
to perceive their direction.
And this builds
up more and more,
until we hear the
reverb of a room.
And that reverb tells us a
lot of important information--
for instance, the size of the
room or the materials used.
For instance, a
stone room sounds
different than a room
made out of wood.
And so you see, we perceive a
lot of important information
here.
So now you heard about
spatial audio perception
and the importance of
real-world acoustic modeling.
I'd like to invite,
now, Ian to explain
how we simulate all of this
in VR on a mobile device.
[APPLAUSE]
IAN KELLY: Hello, everyone.
[INAUDIBLE] My name is Ian,
and I'm a software
engineer here at Google.
And I work on some
of the DSP algorithms
that underlie how our spatial
audio technology works.
Today, I'm going to
bring it through,
how it is we spatialize
sounds in virtual reality.
Now, we're all familiar with
the concept of loudspeakers.
Well, with an array of
loud speakers positioned
around a listener's
head, we can begin
to playback audio through the
individual loudspeakers in such
a way that we could
recreate the sound wave,
as if it came from an object
anywhere in space around.
So in this way, we could
create a synthetic sound source
anywhere around the listener.
We use a method that's
known as ambisonics,
in order to calculate
what the signal played
through each loud speaker
needs to be in order
to recreate these sound waves.
And we can use this not just
for the direct sound coming
from the source to the listener,
but also for reflections
coming from the walls.
In this way, we
could also recreate
an artificial environment
around the listener's head.
And with more and
more loudspeakers,
we can move into
three dimensions
and create an array of loud
speakers around the listener.
In that manner,
you could play back
sounds from any
direction-- reflections
from walls, ceiling, or floor.
And with more and
more loud speakers,
you can have a greater
fidelity in the sound waves
you're recreating.
But all of that still
leaves you with one foot
in the real world, so to speak.
Because sure, you have a
synthetic sound source,
synthetic reflections
from surfaces
that aren't really there.
But the loudspeakers themselves
are still very much rooted
in the real world.
And the manner in which
we get around this
is what's known as
binaural rendering.
Now, Julius spoke about the
cues that humans use in order
to localize sounds,
whether they be
the time of arrival differences,
the level differences,
or the changes in the frequency
as a sound moves up and down.
All of this information can
be captured in a special set
of audio filters.
And these are the HRTFs
you might have heard about.
Well, when sound is
played through an HRTF
and then over headphones,
it gives the listener
the impression-- it fools
your auditory system
into thinking-- that a sound
source is somewhere in space.
Well, at Google we used
this to create what
we call virtual loudspeakers.
And we can have a set
of these audio filters
for each loud
speaker around you,
in the large, spherical array.
So a very real sense, when
you're using Google VR,
you have a virtual, spherical
array of loudspeakers
around you at all times.
We move our heads
constantly, and this
is conscious and subconscious.
In fact, your head
is always in motion,
whether you're
aware of it or not.
But when you're wearing a
HMD, this motion is tracked.
And we use that data in order to
rotate all of our sound sources
and all of the reflections
in the opposite direction
to how you're turning your head.
And we do this so
that when you turn,
sources don't track with
you-- but instead, they
stay locked in space.
And you can use all of the
cues that Julius spoke about
in the real world,
in order to localize
sound sources in virtual
environments that we create.
Now, you might naively think
that with this finite set
of loud speakers around
the listener's head,
there would be a finite
number of positions
in which we could
specialize audio,
but that is not the case.
In fact, to explain this,
all you need think about
are the old-fashioned
stereo loudspeakers
you probably have at home.
And one can pan a source
between a pair of loudspeakers
and create a phantom
source anywhere in between.
Well, we do something very
similar, if a little more
complex, using ambisonics to
pan sound sources anywhere
between the virtual loudspeakers
in our spherical array.
In this way, you can
have an audio source
anywhere around your head
and immerse the listener
in a sphere of sound.
And there's also a computational
advantage offered here,
because even as we add
in more and more sound
sources and more and
more reflections,
the number of virtual
loudspeakers that we're
rendering this over
stays constant.
Julius touched upon the
concept of sound propagation--
of a sound wave propagating
from a source to a listener.
Well, a very nice
analogy for this
is the way ripples spread
from a source-- a drop
falling on a pond, outwards.
As they spread outwards,
they diminish in amplitude
because the energy is spread
over a larger and larger area.
Well, this is replicated
in VR, in order
to give a third dimension
to the spatial audio we're
listening to.
As you move towards
or away from sources--
or they do the same for
you-- we model the way
in which the amplitudes
change in the real world,
in order to give you this
sense of distance in your VR
environments.
Take, for example, occlusion.
We use low-pass filtering
in order to model occlusion,
because in the real world,
when a sound wave emanates
from a source and strikes
an object between you
and the source, the
higher frequencies
are reflected backwards
off the source,
while lower frequencies can
diffract around and still reach
the listener's ears.
And by using smoothly-changing,
low-pass filters,
we can accurately recreate
the sounds of real occlusions
in the virtual environments
you're creating.
Now, so far I've talked
about the direct sound--
the sound coming directly from
the source to the listener.
But that is not
where the story ends.
The next thing to
arrive at your ears
are what are called
the early reflections,
and we spatialize the
early reflections.
We calculate the number of
bounces they make off surfaces,
the eventual direction
they're arriving in from,
the time and distance they've
taken to travel there,
and we use this to create
a new set of audio sources,
spatialized on our virtual
array of loudspeakers
all around the listener.
And we do this just for the
first few, early reflections.
For the next few
million reflections,
we do something else--
because not only would it
be computationally expensive,
but it is perceptually not
necessary.
In fact, we can do
better than that.
If you think about what
happens to sound waves
as they bounce
around inside a room,
over time the arrivals at your
ears of the different waves
builds up, and up,
and up, and you
get something that is very much
like white noise-- overlapping
reflections, distorted by the
bounce as they're arriving.
Well, this
white-noise-like portion
is what's generally referred
to as the reverb of a room.
And in the Google
VR audio system,
we have a powerful
reverb engine built in.
It reacts in real
time to changes
in the size and shape
of the environment,
to changes in the acoustic
properties of the surface
materials you have.
It provides a different reverb
to each of the listener's ears.
And this gives you
a very strong sense
of spaciousness-- of a sound
being without your head.
We provide a reverb
that decays differently
at different frequencies.
Because in the real
world, if I clap by hand,
the sound waves dissipate
at different rates,
depending on frequency.
We model all of
this so that we give
the most realistic-sounding
reverb we possibly can.
And all of it is done reacting
in real time on mobile.
Now, shown here is a
highly-simplified audio graph,
but it captures many of the
key components in our system.
We take in mono-audio.
We spatialize it over our
virtual loudspeaker array.
We calculate the
early reflections--
where they arrive in from.
And we provide an
advanced reverb system.
And all of this is
rendered binaurally,
over a pair of headphones,
reacting in real time
to listeners' head
movements, changes
in the source's position, and
changes in the environment's
size, shape, and
surface materials.
And I haven't even
had time to mention
all of the different
effects we're applying.
There are other things like
complex directivity patterns
for a source's emission,
the ability to play back
ambisonic sound fields.
And in order to see at all,
what you're going to have to do
is just go and download
the Google VR SDK
and start playing around
with it yourselves.
And in order, now, to bring
you through our SDKs and APIs,
I'd like to welcome
onto the stage
my friend and colleague,
Alper Gungormusler.
ALPER GUNGORMUSLER: Thanks.
IAN KELLY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ALPER GUNGORMUSLER:
Hey, everyone.
My name is Alper.
I'm a software engineer on
the Google VR audio team,
focusing on the
development of our SDKs.
So now we've covered how our
spatial audio system works.
Let's take a look
at how you can use
it to easily enable spatial
audio in your virtual reality
experiences.
So as part of the
Google VR SDK, we
target three main platforms--
Android, iOS, and Unity.
With our native SDKs,
for Android and iOS,
we provide you all
the tools you need
to add special audio to any apps
or games you wish to create,
with a simple few
function calls.
So to give you an idea
how this looks like,
let's take a look
at our Android SDK.
Here you see a short code
snippet written in Java .
It demonstrates all the
steps required for you
to play back specialized
audio in your Android app.
So we can break this down
into four simple steps.
First, we initialize our
spatial audio engine.
This is basically
responsible for everything
unrelated in the
Google VR system.
Of course, this wouldn't do
much without any audio sources.
Right?
So here, we create our audio
source-- or as we call it,
our sound object-- with
a simple function call.
So after the creation, you
can manipulate its properties,
such as its volume or its
position, as seen here.
Then once you are happy with
the settings, all left to do
is to play the sound
at the desired time.
So what about environment, then?
We worked really hard to provide
a solution as simple and as
intuitive as possible
for you to add room
effects into your environments.
These room effects can be
edited or modified any time,
with a single function call.
So as you can see here,
all you need to think about
is the size and the
surface materials
of the room you are in.
Then our audio system
will handle the rest
to add up your audio sources
to the environment you've just
selected.
And that's it.
You're all set.
So we also provide an audio
plugin for the Unity game
engine, with an even wider
set of options to play with.
With this plugin, you can
create and build your apps
to any VR headset
you wish to use.
So let's take a look.
Here, let's say you have this
guitar object in your Unity
scene, and you want to
specialize the sound.
So here, all you need to
do is to attach Google VR
audio source components onto it.
Then with this component,
you have all these basic game
parameters, such as muting,
looping, or changing
the volume of the sound.
And more interestingly,
we provide
you these two additional
properties-- directivity
and occlusion effects-- which
can be very useful from the VR
point of view.
So let's first
take a look at how
the directivity property works.
So the directivity
of an audio source
can be used to change the
way you hear the sound.
So imagine you are
walking around this guitar
in the real world.
You would hear its [INAUDIBLE]
sound differently from one way
to another.
For instance, you would
hear it much louder
when you're just in front
of it than behind, right?
So with the directivity
property, and using
these directivity
patterns, you can precisely
control how this
should sound like.
So as seen here, you can change
the shape of this pattern
by using the Alpha
parameter you can see here
to control how it
should sound like when
approached from different
angles all around.
And in addition to that,
with the Sharpness parameter
you can actually adjust,
smoothly, the width
of the shape, accordingly.
And by choosing the
right parameters, Alpha
and Sharpness, you can
closely match the directivity
of real-world objects in your
virtual reality environment.
So our guitar object
would not usually
be alone in the
environment, right?
So there can be different
objects, obstacles,
walls interact all around.
To achieve this
interaction dynamically,
we use our occlusion effects.
So for instance,
here in this example,
the sound of this guitar object
should be blocked by the walls
when it's out of the view.
Right?
So once you enable
occlusion for the guitar,
we automatically detect
all the physical colliders
in the scene, which
occludes guitar's
[INAUDIBLE] to the listener, to
apply this effect accordingly.
In fact, you can even go further
and add more and more obstacles
in between, to amplify
this effect in real time
or mobile during gameplay.
So to simulate the acoustic
environment itself,
we use Google VR Audio Rooms.
As you can see
here on the right,
we have a wide
range of parameters
selected to customize the
very room you wish to create.
So you can use surface
materials to determine
how the sound waves
should get deflected
from each wall of your room,
and how they're affected
in different frequencies.
Then we provide
additional effectivity
on reverb properties, to
fine-tune this outcome.
So here, parameters
such as gain and time
can be used to adjust the
loudness and time of your room
sound.
Moreover, you can use
the brightness parameter
to adjust and balance the low
and high frequencies, which
can be very useful when you
want to simulate how empty
or how full your room
should sound like.
For instance,
decreasing this value
dramatically can be
a perfect solution
when you want to
make your room feel
like it's full of furniture.
So of course, with all these
parameters to select from,
it's totally up to
your imagination
to create your own,
unique-sounding world.
So you see, here are
dozens of surface materials
for each wall of your room.
For instance, you can
use surface materials
like marble or
sheetrock when you
want to create more [INAUDIBLE]
environments, such as caves
or cathedrals.
On the other hand, you
can go for something
like a heavy curtain when
you want to have more damped,
dry-sounding environments.
And here one thing worth
remembering, again,
that all the parameters we've
been talking about so far-- all
those properties can be updated
and manipulated in real time.
So as Ian previously
mentioned, our audio system
will react immediately
to every change
you make in the environment,
in real time during gameplay.
So to simply put, there are
just limitless possibilities
in the types of experiences you
can go for, for your audience.
And for that, I'm
now handing over
to Adam, who will be talking
more about the user experience
side, for designing
for special audio.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM GLAZIER: Thanks, Alper.
Hi, I'm Adam, and I'm a
user experience designer.
And over the past year, I've
been designing apps for VR,
for the Daydream team.
During this experience we've
learned a lot of things,
integrating this plugin.
And one thing I can say is that
it performs extremely well,
even against real-world tests.
So today I'm going to share
some design considerations
that we've learned for that.
The fundamental building
blocks you'll be working with
are the audio room, the
GVR soundfield sources,
and the GVR audio sources.
So let's take a look
at the room model.
Room models provide early
reflections and reverb,
and the materials of
the walls around you.
They make a living room
sound like a living room,
or outdoors sound
like an outdoor scene.
It's really easy to make these
rooms sound however you want,
because you have
so much control.
You can change the
materials of the walls,
and the floor, and the ceiling,
make the walls transparent,
and connect different
rooms together
to get different sonic
sounds from different parts
of the room.
It's super powerful.
It's easy to make a living
room sound like a cave,
or a cave sound
like a living room.
So when you're thinking
about the ambience
of a scene-- like the ocean
waves in the distance,
or swaying trees,
or birds-- there's
two ways that you can
make these sounds happen.
You've got the GVR soundfield
sources and the audio sources.
The soundfield sources
playback ambisonic audio files.
These are similar to
how a 360 photo works,
or a SkyBox in your app.
You hear sound from
all directions,
from one audio file.
Ambisonic sources don't
respond to the user moving
in a direction, like
walking, but they
do respond to head rotation.
So they work really
good for sounds
that are in the distance,
when you need a complex scene
with a lot of ambience.
For things that do move,
use the audio sources.
For instance, dropping an
audio source on a bird--
it just sounds
natural, whether it's
flying near you or far away.
You can also use audio
sources as ambient objects.
So imagine sprinkling
audio sources
all around your environment.
As the user walks
around, they'll
hear these sounds go by
them, and it will just
feel super natural.
So as Julius mentioned
earlier, we move our heads
to locate sounds.
But because users aren't
always moving their head,
we can do a little
trick for them.
When there's something
out of their field of view
that demands
attention, that we want
them to be able to
precisely locate,
you can animate the
position of that sound.
Users don't notice
that happening,
and when they look at it
you stop animating it,
and they instantly locate it.
A similar thing that happens is
that when you repeat the sound,
users are more
likely to locate it.
In addition, if you have
a single sound file that's
comprised of many
complex elements,
it achieves the same effect.
Let me give you an example.
Imagine you lose
your phone at home,
and your ring tone is a
single sine wave beep.
When that ring tone
happens, you're probably
not going to find your phone.
You might even think
it was the dishwasher,
or that you were hearing
things altogether.
But if that beep happens
even one more time,
you're much more
likely to locate it,
and you'll know
you're not crazy.
When you're picking your
sounds for your app,
there's important
sonic characteristics
to take in mind
if you want users
to be able to spatially
locate sounds, and have
them sound more realistic.
As Julius mentioned
earlier, the occlusion
from your head and the ear
shape filter the full frequency
spectrum of audio.
So with this in mind, make
sure that your sounds have
a broad range of frequencies.
Avoid using sounds that are
lacking in high frequencies.
Avoid really quiet sounds,
or really simple sounds
like a sine wave beep.
These simple tones--
like a sine wave beep--
are even difficult to
spatialize in the real world.
Audio sources take mono files.
And there's thousands
of tools and libraries
available to get sound effects
for your games and experiences.
With ambisonic audio, this
is just up and coming.
There's not a lot
out there right now,
but over the next year,
expect to see a host of tools
and libraries for these.
But to get started right now,
there's two ways to do this.
You can use a
plugin-- like this one
from Ambix-- to take
your mono or stereo files
and map them to a
3D ambisonic sphere.
On that sphere, you can
animate the position of sound
so they match what you
see visually in the scene.
You can add audio effects,
and then output your mix
to a 4-channel ambisonic file.
The second way
you can do this is
by recording your own ambisonic
files with a microphone,
like the Zoom H2n.
With these microphones, it's
just like a 360-degree camera.
You can drop it anywhere
in a room, outside,
and capture all sound
from all directions.
Finally, when you get your
experiences up and running,
it's really important
to check your work.
Make sure that what you see
and what you hear match.
It just needs to sound natural.
So let me share an example
that we stumbled upon.
We had an ocean scene that
was this low-poly ocean that
was not moving, and we threw
some sound of waves crashing.
And it just felt really wrong.
So one tip is just,
look around your scene.
See what's moving,
and put sounds
for things that are moving or
things that are out of view,
that you would expect to hear.
When you're testing your
app, if your experience
allows users to
roam freely, we've
seen that users love
finding these sound sources
and putting their ear
right up next to them.
So make sure the sounds you're
using are really high-quality,
and that no matter where
you are in the experience,
the sounds are natural.
And when you do
check your work, make
sure to check on headphones--
different types of headphones.
These provide the best
spatial audio experience.
Try not to test your
work on laptop speakers
or cellphone speakers.
So to get started right now,
check out the links to the SDK,
and check out the demo app.
It's a fun example
of how good this is.
We'll also be posting things in
the Spaces app-- some examples
and tutorial videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]